have you ever had your plans
ruined by the weather
what if i told you i have an idea
how to stop hurricanes from wrecking
your day and
that it involves liquid nitrogen
how exactly would liquid nitrogen
stop a hurricane how much of this
icy cold substance would we need
[Music]
and how would we pull this off
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you could freeze a hurricane
wait why would we need liquid nitrogen
couldn't we just get vibe with a lot of
ice
i don't believe this well in 1947
nobel prize winning chemist irving
langmuir
led a united states military experiment
to pour
ice into hurricane king to make it lose
its strength
um it didn't quite go as planned
oops and that isn't even the craziest
thing
we humans have come up with some of us
would be happy to blow up a hurricane
with a nuke
[Music]
or push a swirling storm away by
pointing a lot of fans at it
but that's a story for another time
for now let's get back to liquid
nitrogen
nitrogen has a boiling point of minus
196 degrees celsius and
it has the power to freeze things
instantly
and if we poured some liquid nitrogen
into a
baking hurricane it should make it go
away
but how exactly would we do it
why does cooling a hurricane sound like
a great idea
well hurricanes happen when warm ocean
water
causes the rise of moist air from its
surface
this creates a cycle of clouds that form
and
spin rapidly as particles get heated
they move faster and spread out farther
from each other
that makes the winds blow faster until
they eventually
grow into a violent storm
warm water is what drives hurricanes
and the easiest way to stop this
disastrous storm
is to cool the ocean water the idea is
simple
if you released liquid nitrogen into the
ocean
it would instantly evaporate and
warm water would act as a fuel for this
evaporation
as the water particles were losing their
energy to the nitrogen
water molecules would begin to slow down
they would come
closer and closer together until they
formed ice
the cooler temperature would then slow
down the winds
and that would end the storm
theoretically if only it were that
simple
we know that hurricanes thrive off warm
water
and warm moist air and we know that
cooling down the water and air around
the hurricane
should stop this disaster the problem is
hurricanes are large the central part of
a hurricane
called the eye can be anywhere from 30
to 65 kilometers in diameter
your best bet would be to freeze the
hurricane all around
not just its eye the hurricane
is traveling at speeds of 120 kilometers
per hour
and that makes its average diameter
roughly
60 kilometers and its circumference
about 500 kilometers so by
our calculations to surround a hurricane
and freeze it
you would need over 32 000
metric tons of liquid nitrogen
that would be like having 16
olympic-sized swimming pools filled with
the stuff
that's a lot of liquid nitrogen to
transport
and how could we even deliver all this
to the hurricane's location
well i'd say we would need a lot of
helicopters
the biggest heavy lifter of the
helicopter world can carry
about 20 000 kilograms so
if you got your hands on this deck you'd
require
over 1600 of these copters to carry the
load
that sounds like a pretty expensive
endeavor
now imagine you had all the necessary
resources and
you were about to dump all that liquid
nitrogen
into the ocean now what well
if you were one of those brave
volunteers transporting the liquid
nitrogen
you should be ready for one thing i'm
ready
it would be painfully difficult to
breathe
that's because once you released it into
the water
the liquid nitrogen would evaporate
the air around you would have too much
nitrogen
and not enough oxygen so better grab an
oxygen tank
but that's just the beginning of the
trouble
freezing that much of the surface of the
ocean could block
sunlight from deeper waters this
would interfere with marine plant
photosynthesis
marine plants form the base of the food
chain in the ocean
they provide nearly half of the oxygen
that we breathe
and don't get me started on how
unbearable life would be without oxygen
you'd probably have to carry tanks
around and
figure out a way to help the animals
looks like you'd be better to wait for
the hurricane to die off
naturally usually that takes about 12 to
24 hours
freezing a hurricane with liquid
nitrogen would be expensive
dangerous and likely impossible
but if you like the idea of using liquid
nitrogen to cool something down
maybe you could pour it into a volcano
well that's a story for another
what if